that your job is partly to understand
situations you haven't read about you're
all in unique professional fields of
practice you've you all are surrounded
by constraints and opportunities uh and
Nuance that are different than everyone
else's and much of what you learn needs
to function in the service of figuring
out what you still need to know so think
of yourself
as Scholars using the the general
Frameworks and tools we've provided you
to enhance your understanding of the
unique things you're specifically
charged with engaging
and the final sort of prong of Purdue's
sort of identity is this notion of
Engagement which some people might call
service
so yes we want you to be
tackling the problems that you're faced
with in your your day-to-day life in
your jobs but we like to think of
Engagement as something maybe even a
little broader how can you use your
skills your talents your expertise to
enhance the the communities you're a
part of so uh whether that's at the
local level state level a national level
or even a global level
think about opportunities that you can
give back through your expertise to
those around you in meaningful ways so
those are things you know I'd like you
to just sort of think about these are
core issues that Purdue likes to think
about and organize our entire University
structure around we're proud of your
accomplishments we want you to go out
and uh do great things uh with your
expertise and knowledge and experience
and let us know how we can support you
on that Journey thanks for including me
in this ceremony
thank you Professor it's our honor to
have you here
thank you very much now I would like to
take the moment and read or even sponsor
Mr kashab dilal chief operations officer
at simply learn kaship drives the
business growth strategy and its
execution through product Innovation
product marketing and brand building
over to you Mr Kasher
thanks uh thanks everyone and Professor
Bart special thanks to you to address
our group of students graduating today I
think for me it's a privilege to be here
you know it's amazing to see so many of
you and all the time and effort that has
gone into completing this program
huge congratulations to all of you it's
not easy to go through the program you
know dedicate time over such a long
period regularly sometimes over weekends
um and and I would also you know pass on
a huge thanks to your families as well
because you know with all the work
pressures family commitments along with
that taking time out and doing this
program I think hats off to all of you
in the effort that has gone into it
um I think the programs that you have
done uh with Purdue University and
simply learn I think they would arm you
with the skills that the industry is
looking for we take great pride in the
programs that we put together to make
sure that you exit those programs with
the skills that can help you fast track
your careers and pursue New Visions and
you know new goals that you have to
achieve on your work life as well as
many of you uh in terms of starting
businesses or starting projects that can
explore or new new domains and new
exciting opportunities that would be
open to you
um
I think apart from that I would also
really encourage that you know the kind
of uh experience that you've had in the
program and and you know the difference
that it would have made to your lives if
each of you could also take this as a
mission that you know how can you uh
recommend and get at least one more of
your friend or colleague to think about
uh investing time to upskill and pick up
new skills I think that's a that's a
great cause it's something that we are
very passionate about that's one of the
small Pleasures that we have at simply
learn that you know you are you're
working at a company where you're also
helping people get ahead in their lives
and and we would love your help to kind
of spread the message and get more
people to invest time and pick up new
skills these are certain insights which
are uh you know just wanted to share it
with the larger group that you know some
of the top domains where we've had a lot
of people graduating uh you know 280
people in data science
um similar large numbers in other
domains I'm sure uh you know this shows
some of the areas which are very uh high
in demand and very sought after in the
market and uh great to be in this forum
where a lot of you have graduated from
these programs
um
yeah I think I would uh congratulate
congratulate you once again and uh great
to be here I will pass it back to the
team to take it forward and looking
forward to hearing stories from some of
you that what was the experience like
and uh how it sets you up for more
success in the future
thank you Mr Kasha thank you very much
moving on it's time to rejoice in your
accomplishments my colleague Anthony
mittal and I will collectively honor
each and every one of you who has
completed the program we will also
recognize all the Achievers in each
category and names will be called out by
program
we will also have a few of our graduates
share their experience with us as we
proceed
we apologize in advance if we
mispronounce on any names
also I would like to add that in case he
missed out on any name please do not
worry you can always reach out to us and
we will surely accommodate you in the
next complications ceremony
moving on to the first set of graduates
we have is for profession certificate
program in data science
in this category we have kishan Suraj
Ashish omkar Avinash
Amit Salim Ali and Sheriff
congratulations to all of you next up we
have amul Michaels gopal Siva rajashekar
harisha Rohan Vishal sandhi and kaushik
congratulations to all of you
next up we have shares nagarjuna Ankita
Rahul Kiran archana malvika sparshini
congratulations to all the achievers
next up we have Meenakshi indu
shravantis
Lakshmi maldika saloni Krishna Kumari
and shida congratulations to all of you
next up we have Elisha meghna Indica
siddam seti Bindu sushma gopinath and
kedar congratulations all of you
congratulations to all of you
next up we have Sai Bharat Sachin
abhijeet and dhanush congratulations to
all of you
next up we have glandin gulapuri mandir
ruchira Naga Costco
venkatesh
vikasa and Aloo congratulations everyone
congratulations all of you
next up we have Ashish Ashish rathore
Ashok astik abhinash Akash
ayushi sambaran Bernard banushree
ranjeet Suraj saniksha Brad Robert
congratulations to all of you
next up we have chakravarti
chandreshri Clinton Daisy Daniela
Michelle Diana Deepak Danny darar
Muhammad
ritesh Abdul Rahman clavina and sadish
congratulations all of you
ibani Muhammad akbal praves Eric Fatima
femina hemant Priya Gita gaurav gopal
Chandra Greg Shan himja Tui Ina indusri
Rafael and Iran congratulations all of
you
next up we have Jagdish Jiva jivan
Anjali hinji
udil karpaga Barun Kavita kotsbutz
ketan Christos jisma omkar Surya
Leslie Faisal and lokesh congratulations
everyone
next up we have
Luciana lovekush Muhammad Rahul Manas
Mahesh Manisha Aaron menkong malihing
sangya mithuna Monica nilene mayur
Muhammad
Niraj and shiching congratulations
everyone
next up we have nishtil Nisha Tyron
Usama pavama Puja prachi Chetan prati
pratibha pratik Shroff Priya
priyadarshini priyam Harish and charos
rajat Kumar Singh and Rajesh
congratulations everyone next up we have
Rajiv Rashmi Ravi Teja Rodrigo Rita riti
Ricardo Purina Ricardo Federico Ron
Murray Lakshmi ruchira Rudolph
sayam surekha saloni Sam and Sandeep
congratulations everyone
next up we have Shana swapnil swaraj
Syed
congratulations to everyone
congratulations to all the Achievers in
data science category now before we move
forward we would like to call one of our
graduates to share her experience with
us can we please move Miss Bindu to the
panelist
hello bendu I am requesting you to
unmute yourself and switch on your video
while addressing thank you
thank you everyone uh I hope I'm audible
yes indu you are thank you thank you so
good morning and good evening everyone
um I'm a software developer with 10
years of experience and I was curious
about data science and machine learning
for quite some time actually and I'm
glad that I found this program in data
science from Simply learn which is in
collaboration with Purdue University
uh the trainers in addition to the Deep
vast and practical knowledge of the
subject matter they also had what it
takes to be a great teacher they all
wanted their students to succeed so they
also imparted a wisdom they had
collected during the course of their own
learning to us I want to thank all of my
teachers from the bottom of my heart
a few words about simple and support I
still can't believe this kind of amazing
support exists I have a four-year-old
son and I work full time so whenever I
needed to take a break from my learning
due to some personal or professional
reasons they understood my problem and
helped me stay in the program and assign
me to a later badge thank you simple and
support
although they are not listening to my
testimonial today I would also like to
thank my family my parents my sister and
her family my brother and his family to
babysit my son so that I could attend
the evening classes I would like to
thank my little son for letting me study
when he actually wanted to play with me
in my job I am getting appreciation as
well as work related to the knowledge I
got from this course and it will
definitely help me get involved in the
kind of projects I want
for giving me this excellent opportunity
to scale up and stay relevant in the job
market my best wishes and regards to my
fellow Learners teachers simply learn
and last but not least by the University
thank you
thank you thank you for sharing your
story your experience with us we are
honored to be a part of your journey and
all the very best for your future
endeavors and your future projects I I
wish you all the success thank you very
much
thank you mohini thank you and
congratulations everyone
thank you thank you so much
for the next set of graduates we have is
for professional certificate program in
business analysis
and I would like to congratulate
nikhil Muhammad
chaitan Kapil kavya Dinah Praveen and
Abdullah congratulations everyone
next up we have subramanya Meenakshi
Kunal Hussain Anna Christina Monica
gurvinda juhi and sneham congratulations
everyone
next we have vidyaradhavan kishori
likhit arnab Alvina Tracy
congratulations everyone
next we have sugar
shubham and Indiana congratulations
everyone
next we have shovhika lavisha
rohanana rushiraj and
congratulations everyone
next we have husband
Christine abilash abhinay Abhishek
Abhishek kachava Pamela
congratulations everyone
next we have ameen Amil
Amna amol Rahul
willeswari and Morris congratulations
everyone
next we have right Yuan
Hasan Dao David
Deborah
Deepa
same
congratulations everyone
next we have Dolly Eric Faith Felix
haritha garish kensham women
congratulations everyone
next we have with the German
J
James
congratulations everyone
next we have lokesh Leticia Mark miles
Nicole
Emmy Oksana Allah
congratulations everyone
next we have Puja
purnima sudeep
prakash
Praveen Priyanka
Radha Rahul Rahul prasanna
congratulations everyone
next up we have
reshma Sayed Raza Rahul rishika Riya
Rahul matar rodrigue Rohan Rohit
vishwaraj sabreem Sachin Kumar mohsen
Sai Krishna and Arjun Sara Satya Prasad
and Sarah congratulations everyone
next we have Sam green
pallavi Shilpa shivangi shramika
rajashri
Muhammad sudaya Ali Siddharth
Swati saurabh ketan
Smitha sneha saurabh and Shane
congratulations everyone
next we have SRI SRI budget
um Thomas
congratulations everyone
next we have Veera venkatesh
venkateswara Avinash Rohit vibhor vidhi
vishakha
vamsi Krishna srishti Allah
Puja gentle and Avicii many many
congratulations to all of you
before we move forward we would like to
invite one of a learner
gurvinda who would like to share our
experience with all of us can we please
move on to the panelist
hello I am requesting you to unmute
yourself and switch on your video while
you speak thank you
can anyone hear me hello
hi great I'm not sure if you are able to
see me as well
their videos on okay great thank you so
much uh I'm very delighted to be part of
this graduation ceremony today uh again
introducing myself my name is gurvinder
mudhar and I have completed PG uh
program in business analysis with simply
learn I am a healthcare ID professional
uh and I was looking for an opportunity
to upskill my my uh profile my
Professional Profile by adding some
business analysis skill I did my
research uh in the market to find out
which course will affect best to cater
to my need at the moment and I can came
to a conclusion that this course uh that
I availed uh was the best fit as a
simply Learned was offering it and it is
getting backed up by Purdue University
and my experience with this course uh
the classes the structure of classes and
simply learn as a whole has been
fantastic it has been outstanding
experience and I truly loved uh the the
structure of the course uh the extensive
knowledge that instructors had and the
way they engage all the students was
phenomenal and this course has been an
ideal combination of virtual learning
and Hands-On training that I loved and
all the Practical demos that were uh
offered and the course helped me into
reinforcing all the concepts and
techniques that I learned during uh the
the classes and this course did give me
did definitely give me a good boost into
my uh professional uh expertise and all
in all I will say that it is a huge
privilege to be part of this graduation
ceremony today and
um to share my experience with some
simply learn as well as with Purdue
University
and I would also like to congratulate
all my fellow Learners on passing out
and I'm uh wishing all the best to
everyone thank you so much
thank you for sharing your experience
kulwinder I wish you the best with your
future thank you
now we would like to announce a
graduated budget learners for
professional certificate program in
digital marketing in this program we
have Deepak sahil srivatsan gaurav ini
Sayed
Carol priyanshi and Rahul
congratulations everyone next up we have
Kiran preet motuli mohana Marshall
adarsh prativ Naveen Raja pratyusha and
visha and astha congratulations all of
you
congratulations all achievers next up we
have Amit taranjeet munish Maya Amber
Jyoti Vishal Arpita Ankit Asher Abhijit
Abhishek Kumar gitanjali Ami akansha
anirban Aman amarjeet Amita and Amara
congratulations all of you foreign
congratulations everyone
next up we have junette Kamal Karthik
Karthik
Lakshmi
lavanya lavanya nandesh
congratulations everyone
next up we have murali
next up we have Chandra Kumar rajendra
Rama rameshwari Ramya rashika Rini
foreign
Sonia samya sripana hariharan rajat
South subin Suman and sanjon
congratulations everyone
next up we have
taranjitara tabasi sushmita Kiti Shikhar
vaishnavi valasaran vikas Vijay viplov
Vivek vinayak nitin Susana Suraj
yadavinder deshali and zahana
congratulations everyone
congratulations everyone now before we
move on to the upcoming category we
would like to hear from one of our
graduates Mr rajit chandran can we
please move him to the panelist
hello Ajay I am requesting you to unmute
yourself and switch on your video while
you speak thank you
thanks much uh Team I say it's an
exhaustive list of names that you got
guys are reading out so you know great
job on reading out the names and keeping
that smile on your face so uh greetings
of the day to each and every one over
here and uh as the host introduced me
I'm Ajay I'd like to be addressed as AJ
right so you know when I start this I I
would like to start with an adage you
know it's generally said that you know
education is a passport to the future
but tomorrow belongs to those who
prepare for it today now that's
something that simply learned definitely
gives you it helps you be future ready
now the courses that they offer when I
went to their plethora of uh you know uh
offerings that they have they definitely
have few courses that has now caught my
interest I did take digital marketing I
got certified by digital marketing
wonderful experience but now that's
definitely inspired me to go for the
next one which is the neural networks
right for those who are listening to me
neural networks AI iPhone found the
course you need to be really good so I'm
looking forward to that simply learn
team but then in short my experience
with you all in the last six months
fabulous right I had uh you know classes
over the weekends the trainers were Fab
you know we went through three trainers
in my batch now uh starting from 22
Stephen Raj to uh we had cm manjunar and
these two laid the foundation for us and
then you know it topped up wonderfully
well with our trainer Ave Rai who in
indeed was you know I would say an
epitome of patience for a few Learners
you know like me I'm pretty new to this
particular field but the way that he
took that pains to go to depths to make
you understand that simple concept of
digital marketing hats off to you and
for having a trainer uh such as aware I
with you all right and yes so wonderful
I I think I can go endless uh speaking
about the good experience that I have
but I'll keep it short sweet because I
understand There's a constraint of time
so thanks again uh starting from the top
management I think we have questions we
have uh Stuart here right and Professor
bat who's here and mohini and Anjali
great job team will be you know coming
back for the next convocation hopefully
you're most welcome and thank you so
much uh it was delightful to hear from
you and all the very best for your
future and for your future learnings and
your projects so all the very best and
thank you very much thanks much thank
you
let us now felicitate our graduates for
professional certificate program in
digital transformation
and I would like to congratulate afroz
Jaya Kumar are venkata flosy
priyadarshini
John ranjan priyank and Guru Rajan
congratulations everyone
next up we have soumya
Manoj Kumar shresh
sanjeevan Tia Shri ganeshram Mayuri and
Ashwin congratulations everyone
next up we have mozam engineer
Malika Ashok kumaran Rajan Kamal and
uprapali congratulations everyone
next we have jignesh Alo nihi Akash Amit
Kumar anjulatha
Ashwin Muhammad Saleem Bali
Pradesh Delhi Praveen Manoj Manoj Kumar
Sharma dilip Divya
congratulations everyone
next we have our venkata Deepak piyush
firas
congratulations everyone
next we have vipul Muhammad Abdul Salam
Neha Karan Puja prishan asmina
puneet Kumar
Rahul rajat
rangarajan rohini
srinivasa samresh and Santosh
congratulations everyone
next we have Santosh Mahesh Shiva
Shankar Satya sujata sukesh Sunil Gautam
tarunendra the slim
and abhori many many congratulations to
all of you
the next set of graduates we have is for
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning and the graduates
are kalpesh Sunil Suresh Kumar vaishali
Christina Franklin Sally grishma
bodhivan and Krishna congratulations
everyone next up we have chakradhar
ujjwal prasanjit madhu Ralph Ramesh
Kumar swathi sampada abhiji jagriti and
Krishna
congratulations everyone next up we have
kabindra Lakshmi chandan
shivangi Preeti Vivian Vishnu deepi and
saurabh congratulations everyone
next up we have Lakshmi sahil ambadi
push-up Bikram and rameshri
congratulations
Anna anupam Anthony Ashok ashitosh
Kalyan Kumar Avinash Priya Muhammad
hennok subramanyam and Baha
congratulations everyone
next up we have chandrashekra cherimanam
shulhi Daisy David Monica Durga Prasad
dushanth Eliza gothman Dr vipin
Fatima shining
congratulations everyone
next up we have madhur gurjit Hans
Hansel Harry
jagrati Jana Jamie Jeremy Johnson John
kangman Muhammad Kapil Amar Kumar Kiran
and prasanna congratulations everyone
next up we have Kamal
kundesh Praveen Lewis Brahim Jose simran
Naveen bobili Manu Mata
muhammadip manjor sir
congratulations everyone
next up we have puran Kumar Nadine
nikhil Nishant pallavi part pavitra V
Krishnan Prabhu
pratiksha puneet ravindra nisi and Rama
congratulations everyone
next up we have grima Richa rachid
rohith
Muhammad Sagar
Sameer sampada Sanju servanan Seema
Seema Mishra deep pink sethuraman
shirish and samya congratulations
everyone
next up we have shubham vikas Sanjay
sojung Shelby hiraj saurabh sridhar
samya Greg saurabh srinivas Rao shubham
Subhash sumanth sunanda
Krishna Kumar congratulations everyone
congratulations everyone now before we
move ahead to the next program I would
like to share one of the testimonials
from one of our graduates I would like
to say thank you
for taking time to write to us we are
always trying our best to make your
experience memorable and we are glad
that we are able to achieve it thank you
so very much Ralph
the next set of graduates we have is for
professional certificate program in data
engineering and I would like to
congratulate
congratulations everyone
next we have added the Akshay Anand
Bernard Muhammad bayazar Khan vikas
Manoj Harish EDU
congratulations everyone
next we have prati Russia Royster Slava
sideville sainath Santosh sashwat Shiva
Kumar shivnetra Smitha somnath Sofia
sushil Kumar Arun Kumar
congratulations everyone
moving on to the next category we have
all Achievers in professional
certificate program in data analytics in
this category we have Karthik amajit
nalandeep Vikram kosovali gitika saurabh
arantra kaushik and Emma congratulations
everyone next up we have Poonam Roshan
Akshay shifali dhamesh sahiti Kushi
and priyambada congratulations next up
we have bronak Jodha shweta nikhil
kalyani yogish Kodi Pusa and Juliana
congratulations everyone
up next we have Abdul abhinanda Abra
Alexis akshata Alexis morals Elise Saida
Anand Ankita ankur Ashley Arun
tripti Avinash Suzanne Ashlynn Tanya
Brian Bruno Coda congratulations
everyone
congratulations everyone next up we have
Latasha libu Lois Manisha Manish mayank
Brenda and milia motion Samuel zetan
bijesh niranjan nemal nizamuddin
punish and pushpak congratulations
everyone next up we have Prasad sharya
Priya V Krishna
Puja ratnesh rishit Kumar Rohan
congratulations everyone
next up we have shihiki jayarama Sanjeev
Smitha sonal Ben Sonia Rahul srikant
srihari SRI vaksini Shivani Stephen
sujata shamsun Rahul tarun Dishon
shalata udaya and upamanya
congratulations everyone last but not
least we have Kiran pranati shivatsa
virgin
venugarlia vikrant the Shaka Yasha Sunni
and zeeling congratulations everyone
before we move on to the next category I
would like to share one of the
testimonials from our graduates Miss
Jorah thank you for taking time to write
to us we are honored to be a part of
your journey all the very best for your
future endeavors and all your future
projects thank you
last but not least we have graduates for
professional certificate program in
digital Supply Chain management
and I would like to congratulate
ravindran jayan Rajiv Arjun prasan vinod
Raj Sagar
congratulations everyone
next we have Abhishek Santosh and
ashwatha congratulations everyone
next we have hariharan Abhishek Chandra
shekhar vadiraj tushan Krishnan Dinesh
deep Gokul Guru Hare Lal Harish
congratulations everyone
next we have Muhammad Narendra nikhilesh
Prashant rajeshri raghul Roberto
Sandeep Kumar sivananda
many many congratulations to all of you
before we move on to our next program I
would like to invite one of our learner
who would like to share his experience
with all of us
can you please move him to the panelist
hello shrikant I am requesting you to
unmute yourself and switch on your video
while you speak thank you
can you hear us
are you there with us
because you can check your audio
settings with the little triangle next
to the uh mute button
am I Audible
yes
okay thank you
sorry about that some technical glitch
no problem
thank you Anjali so good morning uh good
evening everyone uh it's it's a great
privilege to be in this convocation
program I really had a great learning
experience in terms of the course
especially with weekend life classes and
self-learning videos
I was able to improve my abilities
without taking a vacation from work so I
would like to thank Purdue University
and the simply learned team I also like
how flexible the program was allowing me
to fit my studies around other
responsibilities
uh I was also able to broaden my
expertise in the competitive field of
Supply Chain management thanks to the
course materials and Capstone projects
in addition knowing how to use
technology to enhance operational
effectiveness and decision making uh
throughout the supply chain so it will
definitely help me Stand Out Among my
colleagues also the simply learned
support staff was quite helpful and
encouraging in case if you needed any
assistance or any problems or with sir
also the extension of the cohort I am
really happy to have a finished a post a
graduation program at a university with
a stellar reputation powered by simply
learn so thank you and congratulations
to all my fellow learners
thank you for sharing your experience we
are really happy you had a wonderful
experience and all the best for your
future and we wish
thank you so much
thank you
next
we move to my favorite and the exciting
part which I believe all of you are also
excited for
so now it's time to award our winner
we know you all are Achievers because
this path has not been easy for you yet
there are a few Learners who went above
and beyond and demonstrated their
competitive spirit for today we have
planned two sets of awards and the first
category of the word is the scholar
award
in this section we recognize the top two
Achievers in each program who completed
their live sessions projects and
assessments with the highest cumulative
scores
first I would like to call out the
scholars professional certificate
program in data science
and the winners are dhanush who scored
89.7 percentage and Hansen who scored
86.3 percentage
moving on to our next program in Ai and
machine learning we have pushani who
scored 89.7 percentage and Murad who
scored 87.4 percentage many many
congratulations to all of you
moving on to our next program which is
professional certificate program in data
analytics I would like to congratulate
lasagne who scored 87.6 percentage and
yogesh who scored in 6.7 percentage
now the next program is professional
certificate program in data engineering
one by Adrian who scored 81.6 percentage
and aging who scored 80.5 percentage
congratulations to all of you
next up we have professional certificate
program in business analysis and the
winners are Diana who scored 84.4
percentage
who scored 83.3 percentage
now the next program is professional
certificate program in digital marketing
and the winners are omkar who scored 90
percentage and keep Tikka who also
scored 90 percentage congratulations to
all of you
moving on to our next program which is
professional certificate program in
digital Supply Chain management we have
giant who scored 81.7 percentage and
Chandra shekhar who scored 81.6
percentage
now moving on to our next program in
digital transformation we have Shri
ganeshram who scored 89.5 percentage and
Rahul who scored 86.4 percentage
once more many many congratulations to
all our Scholars
before we move forward
I would like to invite one of a learner
SRI Ganesha who would like to share his
experience with all of us
can we please move him to the panelist
hello Ganesh I am requesting you to
unmute yourself and switch on your video
while you speak thank you
hi hi everyone I hope I'm Audible and
visible as well
yes
thank you uh hello everyone and
greetings to you all across time zones
and thank you for really providing me
this opportunity I am very happy for
this award and it really feels good and
it's indeed a pleasure and a privilege
being here today and I'm extremely
delighted to share my learning
experience with spread over the last six
months before that a quick word about me
I'm a chemical engineering professional
with about 29 years of experience spread
across different Industries events and
when I really started exploring
continued education I've done a couple
of uh Iams and iits and the few
parameters I was evaluating were like
you know relevance value add and
something which looks to be
strengthening your own tribal knowledge
as well as late one future proof and
digital transformation indeed came
across as one of the most promising
courses and I'm extremely happy that I
have opted for that and that's what we
are here today and it was an extremely
engaging and a fantastic six months I
would say after enrolling one of the
first few thoughts that I had was oh my
gosh like Saturday Sundays evening
spread over six months you're going to
lose all your weekends but with every
passing session the excitement was like
continuously building up and I started
looking forward to all the weekends it
was like instead of TGIF it was like
thank God it is Saturday or thank God
it's a Sunday that that that's how good
it was I mean thanks to everyone for
making that happen and coming to the
course that says the overall learning
experience was indeed awesome over
awesome I would say and the course
contents were pretty well curated to
provide a contemporary learning
experience through strong fundamentals
Market insights and relevant case
studies modules like your digital
disruption transformation strategies
agile marketing leadership there are
very well staged together and delivered
a very seamless learning experience
through experience faculty I mean that
was equally important and kudos to all
the faculty members and in a nutshell
like if I could summarize the outcome of
six months is a strong upskilling
personally speaking to myself in the
digital space and a transferred me
rather digitally transfer me I would say
uh you know I mean that's a pun intended
part and the course of the knowledge
gain is actually a springboard and I'm
sure this is going to be a great value
for my own career progression going
forward and making me more future ready
and and I would definitely take this
opportunity uh all of you for thanking
each and everyone from what you and
simply learned for making this happen
and bringing together this wonderful
program and sincerely appreciate that
special shout out for all the faculty
members for sharing their time knowledge
efforts and indeed that made this they
are the cornerstones and pillars for
this program and thank you everyone and
I also would like to thank and
congratulate my classmates and peers
they made this learning experience
really insightful and interesting as
well like we had a lot of offline
sessions and made a fantastic group all
together and last but not the least
thanks uh Anjali and mohini for
arranging this and others who are
involved in this thank you all bye-bye
our pleasure and thank you so much for
sharing your experience Ganesh it was
glad to hear you had a wonderful
experience thank you so much and all the
best for your future thank you
I feel privilege to announce our next
category of awards the speedrunner award
recognizing Learners who were able to
complete their program from start to end
in the shortest duration
the winners for the first category data
science are Asher who completed the
program in 86 days and Lakshmi who
completed the program in 99 days
next category belongs to Ain machine
learning the winners are dhiraj who
completed the program in 95 days and
Abhishek who completed the program in 99
days congratulations to all the winners
the next category belongs to business
analysis the winners are Oliver Tommy
who completed the program in 60 days and
megha who completed the program in 67
days
next category belongs to professional
certificate program in data analytics
the winners are Zhong Liang who
completed the program in 88 days and
gaurav who completed the program in 117
days congratulations to all the
speedrunnels
upcoming category belongs to data
engineering the winners are Clayton who
completed the program in 77 days and
Suraj who completed the program in 132
days
next category belongs to digital
marketing the winners are Kiran PRI who
completed the program in 94 days and
shamanas who completed the program in
160s congratulations to all the winners
next up we have digital Supply Chain
management the winners are hariharan who
completed the program in 93 days and
qazim who completed the program in 115
days
last but not least we have professional
certificate program in digital
transformation the winners are Shaheen
who completed the program in 70 days and
Manish who completed the program in 94
days
congratulations to all the speedrunners
your speed is attributed to the time you
allocated to your work you prioritize
this program and it really shows thank
you
now I would like to introduce you to the
team behind the scenes the team that has
worked relentlessly to make sure you
have the best learning experience now
this is for you to put a face to the
names you may have heard
interacted within the past year
I would like to start with a Life Class
instructors
they have been the main Rivals of your
Learning Journey
and I would like to express my gratitude
to each one of them on your behalf thank
you very much
another
thank you to Prashant sahu servan and
Rishi ritesh sahil Sayan recording in
progress
Ive Varun
thank you very much
in attendance to say a few words firstly
I would like to invite Mr other mother
in audience to Enlighten our audience to
say few words
can we please move him to the panelist
hello other I am requesting you to
unmute yourself and switch on your video
while addressing the audience thank you
hello
hello yeah am I Audible
yes you are yeah yeah so uh good morning
good afternoon and good evening to time
zone
to each and every one of you for uh
getting the much uh deserved uh you know
certificates from Simply Learning
University
I come with a corporate experience of 38
years and have facilitated over 300
hours of sessions on design thinking and
innovation
uh it was so gratifying to know that in
every batch of mine we had Learners from
across India not only across India but
even from Gulf from UK as well as from
us and uh they were coming from diverse
backgrounds from different sectors with
such a rich experience and there were
great conversations in every session of
mine where they were exchanging their
experiences and we had a lot of quizzes
q a as as well as assessments and course
and uh projects to submit we made a good
use of digital platforms to have you
know Hands-On learning on the concepts
as well and of course the case studies
that we were discussing from hbr added
value to each and every session of mine
and all in all it was a gratifying
experience to be in every batch you know
of design thinking Innovation that I was
facilitating for simply learn and party
University
and once again I'd like to congratulate
each and every learner for getting this
much deserved award and uh thank you so
much simply learn for giving me this
opportunity to speak back again to you
Anjali
thank you for your time
uh now I would like to invite shubham
Pandey to take the mic and Enlighten our
audience with few words
can we please move him to the panelist
hello I'm requesting you to unmute
yourself and switch on your video while
addressing the audience please thank you
yeah can you hear me
yes yes great uh hi everybody thanks for
having me here
and many congratulations to all the
Learners here
you know what it's a big deal
it's a great accomplishment I would say
it's not easy
yeah I used to push you guys to find out
time after work find out time over the
weekend it's not easy I know uh taking
out time when you're walking
taking away time from your family for
your kids it's not easy so it requires a
lot of dedication a lot of hard work so
all the hardships you have gone through
uh
and all the sleepless nights you went
through now now that you have
accomplished the certification this
amazing work you have done and I'm sure
this will help you big time in your
career and many congratulations for your
career
and if you use all this knowledge you
will do very well in the long term as
well it's not about getting any job
right now it's not about getting a
promotion at this moment it will help
you in the long run big time I also want
to thank you guys for all the learning I
had
uh I'll be honest uh we had an amazing
group uh we had Learners from uh
Diversified backgrounds
people having very varied years of
experiences uh in one class we had
people we had Learners uh who were
freshers and we also had Learners who
had 30 years of experience and and we
have to agree to the point that data
science AI is not a very simple subject
especially for those who are new to uh
programming who are new to statistics
and all uh but you made it
and it requires a lot of discussion I
think discussion is the way ahead so uh
because of your thoughts because of your
thought sharing because of your ideas
sharing your experiences uh you are
brought to the table because of all of
that we could achieve all of it so I
also learned a lot from you uh thank you
and uh again many congratulations thank
you
thank you for your kind words
thank you
now I would also like to thank a master
class instructors for delivering
lectures on variety of topic each month
thanks to Sarah professor venkata
Eric Michelle
thank you very much
let us now turn our attention to the
simply learn team who has been
invaluable throughout your Learning
Journey these personal were in charge of
moderating all sessions as well as the
support ticket you send
several of you may have had direct or
indirect interactions with them
a huge thanks to shubham Sanya
foreign
Irene and vikas thank you very much
now moving on to our next team which is
the faculty aggregation team
now thank you to Ashish Poonam Vijay
Jonathan who were in charge of the
lining one of the best trainer thank you
so much
let us now express our gratitude to the
product team this team is in charge of
curating and structuring the program
a huge stance
thank you so much
now let us turn our attention to the
individual in charge of all the
information and curriculum that we see
in the form of live virtual classes labs
and self learning videos huge thanks to
vaishakhi kunan Dr anjana and arushi
last but not least let us thank our
leadership team who manages the learner
success team and regulates the direction
of all programs many times to Abhishek
subhashini goyal Siddharth my co-host
mohini Rahul
Sampras akshita and myself Anjali
let us take a moment to appreciate and
applaud all of the teams for their
ongoing work thank you very much
I would also like to thank everyone
who has actively reviewed us on various
social media Networks we are overjoyed
and grateful to have received your
feedback and admiration
your input has motivated us to work
harder address many problems and move
forward in order to provide you and your
successes a better learning experience
here are our social media handles so you
can stay up to date I hope you stay in
touch
and now
we have reached the conclusion of our
online convocation ceremony
we wish every one of you the best of
luck in your future cuisines we believe
that having goals is the first step
towards success
you came here with an aim and a dream
and we hope you now feel sure that you
have the knowledge and experience to
carry that dream out we are thrilled and
grateful that you chose Purdue and
simply not
we want to leave you with one thought
today
you are now our ambassador to the purge
you simply learn PG programs
people will now follow your footsteps
and you will be there Guiding Light to
success we would request you to be
active in our communities and post some
interesting topics for future Learners
and also keep us posted about your
success stories and do targets so that
we can celebrate and set the right path
for the future Learners as well once
again it's a heartfelt gratitude from us
for you choosing simply learn to be your
partner to skill up
thank you once again everyone for making
time for this event thank you for your
time and for helping to make this even a
success once again many many
congratulations to all our participants
good night good day and best wishes to
everyone thank you